speaker will be Chris Manning from
Stanford thanks very much
[Applause]
okay good morning everybody
so what I want to do today is give a
fairly big picture talk without a lot of
technical detail really about how work
in neural networks for natural language
understanding has been transformed over
about the last 18 months so that what
we've been seeing is that there actually
been huge changes in natural language
processing that there were sort of
methods that were being used in sort of
2040 and 15 and I guess actually
as recently as 2017 I gave talk at the
Symons Institute where I pictured this
is sort of the default way people use
neural networks for natural language
processing but here it is in 2019 and
there's actually been a huge sea change
and the kind of methods that people use
so I wanted to you know give you a sort
of a big picture sense of what and why
things have been and how they've been
changing just so you've got sort of some
idea of the big picture I realized sort
of basically the audience here isn't
natural language processing people in
any level of detail so I'm trying to
give an overview of that and then
towards the end I want to say something
about the idea of having knowledge and
reasoning and neural networks and
whether we can press pushing your
networks closer to the traditional
notions of higher level of cognition and
talk a little bit about how we might try
and do that in some work that I've done
with students in the area of visual
question-answering so that's sort of the
program here of talking about language
models and deep contextual word
representations and then moving on to
whether we can have neural networks that
reason when I got into neural networks
about 2010 the idea that really
motivated me was back when I was a young
person in the 1980s late 1980s early
1990s when neural networks were popular
at the second time from the point of
view of human language which was my
background
it was seen that at that time the huge
limitation of neural network models was
that they didn't seem as if they could
represent the kind of structure that
human languages have so human languages
seem to have this kind of compositional
structure how you put together meaning
so you have something like very good and
you put that together as a unit which
has a meaning of very good but then you
could modify that further with something
like not and get not very good and so
what I was interested in doing was how
could we build a neural network models
that use this kind of compositional
structure of human languages to
understand human languages and with
various people especially Richard
Scioscia worked on that a lot and we've
got some interesting at the time good
results that seem to actually realize
this vision so here's an example of
using these kind of tree structured
models for sentiment analysis so the
sentence is there are slow and
repetitive paths that it has just enough
space to keep it interesting and the
model is able to put a tree structure
over the sentence and correctly work out
that there are slow and repetitive parts
is saying negative stuff about the movie
has just enough space to keep it
interesting is saying positive stuff
about the movie and the positive stuff
wins and so overall this is a positive
sentence and that seems great but in
practice this isn't the way that the
neural network modeling world has gone
that instead these kind of models in
some sense haven't worked out great and
we had argue why they haven't worked out
great there may be too rigid and trying
to sort of use this traditional
linguistic structure or it might partly
also be because these models are sort of
a computational disaster area compared
to the kind of efficient models neural
network models that people have been
able to scale up large scale but you
know this doesn't seem to have actually
been the big success
so what has been the big success and so
the big success
has essentially been taking the idea of
language models a very sort of
traditional simple idea in prediction
that has been used since the 70s for
building statistical models of language
and making it bigger so the idea of a
language model is you've got something
like the students open there and you
want to put a probability distribution
over what's going to come next books
laptops exams minds and so we've got a
word sequence and then we wanting to put
a probability distribution over what
word comes next
and if we add a stopped probability into
our distribution and we can use that to
give us a probability distribution over
texts and this simple idea of language
modeling has essentially been you know
the decades the key part of most
practical natural language understanding
tasks so things like speech recognition
or spelling correction systems as
decoding tasks make use of language
model knowledge to try and work out what
words are likely to be in a certain
context and natural language generation
tasks like machine translation
summarization story generation use
natural use language models everywhere
to try and predict what kind of things
that people are going to say next so how
do you build language models so this is
language models in the dark ages which
is approximately for most people until
about 2012 let's say to pick a number
so essentially what people did was took
a big pile of text and just counted how
often a words come after other words and
he divided and you get conditional
probabilities now that was both what
everybody did till 2012 roughly but sort
of also a disaster area right this is
sort of classic curse of dimensionality
because you know huge number of words
you know one of those dictionaries about
thicker elapsed so 250 thousand words so
if you're sort of wanting to condition
on a couple of words of context and
predict next words you've got 250
million cubed parameters and you're sort
of very quickly into these sort of
number of atoms in the universe kind of
parameters that you'd like to know about
so people were able to build sort of
good models and so these are the sort of
methods people use to do them I mean
first of all we made Markov models which
is say well we can't model a lot of
contexts before the word we're
predicting so let's only use the
previous couple of words or something
like that the data was still really
sparse because of our zillions of
parameters so we had to smooth out our
probability distributions sometimes we
could use more context and sometimes
less and so people used ideas like back
off and mixture distributions to try and
get things work you know so the first
approximation things could be gotten to
work right a lot of the early tools of
natural language tools that many people
will have been exposed to whether it's
things like spelling correction or
machine translation on Google these kind
of technologies powered in the early
days but it was then worked out that you
could do a lot better by using
distributed representations of words as
word vectors and really your Shaw bender
own colleagues pioneered this actually
much earlier around the turn of the
millennium actually in the original
paper but actually it's sort of then
talk about another decade before barely
anybody actually picked up and started
using this idea but the idea now is we
can have a real vector to represent each
word and then we're going to use those
vectors to predict the next word and
that allowed us to solve two problems
firstly we could solve the curse of
dimensionality in a certain sense
because these vectors for words could
share components or directions of
meaning and so therefore we could
generalize across words with similar
meanings but secondly people then
started looking at using recurrent
neural network
to model language and then we weren't
restricted to only conditioning on a
couple of words of context and we could
start conditioning on much longer
context and that really really used
faulty human languages so here's a
sentence from a novel the same stump
which would impale the car of many a
guest in the past 30 years in which he
refused to have removed so if you're
simply building something like an in
gram language model and you're trying to
predict what word comes next after he
refused to have you know whatever would
come to mind he refused to have an
operation he refused to have a dog he
refused to have a child you're not going
to think of Stumpf right you're only
gonna think of Stumpf if I'll sorry I'm
sorry you're not gonna think of removes
you're not going to think of removed
you're only gonna think of removed if
you can see something like stump which
here is about sort of 15 words back and
so that's sort of powerful need for not
using these kind of Markov models model
context okay so essentially what's
happened in the last couple of years is
people have gone a lot further than
before of saying well suppose we just
take these kind of simple neural models
whose job is to predict words and we
start scaling them up to much much much
bigger models that do this job and so
we've sort of seen this progression
where you could have you know models
trained on a hundred million words
models trained on 800 million words
models trained on three billion words
models trained on forty billion words
and people have been getting bigger and
bigger models using vaster and vaster
amounts of computational resources to
train these models the end result has
actually been quite amazing so this is
from the GPT to model that open AI did
which is working as a language model
which predicts
abilities of next words so you can then
just sort of run it and say generate
some next words for me so I'm going to
give the first sentence of a of an
article a train carriage containing
controlled nuclear materials was stolen
and Cincinnati today its whereabouts are
unknown and then just say use a language
model to predict following words from
that and you repeat that over and over
again and so you get a continuation of a
story and we get the incident occurred
on the downtown train line which runs
from coming to the national stations in
an email to Ohio news outlets the US
Department of Energy said it was working
with the Federal Railroad Administration
to find the thief the theft of this
nuclear material will have significant
significant negative consequences on
public and environmental health our
workforce and the economy of our nation
said Tom Hicks blah blah blah blah so
you know this output is actually quite
incredible and it's incredible in two
senses I mean one sense is a linguistic
sense that basically hey this can just
write English that we're not getting
something that sort of full of
grammatical area errors and obviously
broken it's just coming out like
sentences but the other thing that's
kind of incredible is that somehow just
by going to big scale we've built a
model that seems to know about the world
so in our prompt we had a train carriage
nuclear materials Cincinnati which is
all good but well when we start to
generate well it seems to know that
Cincinnati is an Ohio oh it seems to
know that the Department of Energy is
involved with nuclear materials and it
seems to know that the Federal Railroad
Administration is a good thing to invoke
when there's mention of a train carriage
and when you're stolen you might want to
have a thief right it seems to actually
know a ton about the world and that's
kind of impressive and interesting yeah
some kind of processing on top of just
extracting from conditional
probabilities short answer is no none at
all the slightly longer answer is it's
using a particular way to generate this
text and it actually turns out that that
is important so the method that's being
used here is that you're generating from
a truncated probability distribution so
that using our neural network it's got a
probability distribution over all of the
next words and so the method that's used
here which is a successful good method
is say let's truncate that distribution
at the top 30 words and then renormalize
and randomly choose from that those 30
words and that turns out that sounds a
little hokey but that turns out to be a
good method that works really well
because if you always pick the most
likely word you tend to get very generic
and boring text because the most likely
word tends to be a too common word but
if you actually use the whole
distribution there's still too much
probability mass in the tail and
aggregate and once you head out into
that tail you tend to go downhill
quickly so this sort of truncated top
end distribution or sometimes people use
the top you know P proportion of the
probability distribution has proven to
be just a successful mission so I mean
so yeah the grammar just act like which
models learn grammar really well right I
mean even the older Engram models that I
was showing earlier the sort of those
count ones really their grammar locally
is pretty good already because just a
few words is actually pretty good for
grammar normally where the Engram models
were no good at all is in sort of this
longer text generation and understanding
semantics they'd produce things there's
actually grammatically fine that the you
know if you just look at five or six
words in a row
it's just if you read a whole sentence
it made no sense whatsoever even
commentaries brother something in
praises don't agree a number is the art
and the title of that part unknown
business or are incorrect because burn
about isn't clurel it's its whereabouts
is the concept and it should be singular
there so I mean even even I I'm not sure
I quite agree I think both tend to
appear here for various reasons but
anyway we shouldn't find that on the
model right because this pardon italics
was given to it as a prompt and it's
only generating from here so if there's
problem with this part it's the human
beings who designed the prompts it's not
actually the models but I mean yeah I
mean in short yes wrong grammar can
annoy me like hey but you know in truth
human beings aren't perfect themselves
at doing agreement and when there is
intervening material or semantically
complex cases human beings themselves
when they're like errors in agreement
that's actually been several psycho
linguistic studies of that yeah so
that's the obvious wonder which is to
say look maybe it's just ripping
sentences out of its big training set
and it's not really generating anything
interestingly different at all that's
actually not the case and they but they
actually did do a study of that and I'm
slightly I'm slightly making up the
numbers because I don't quite remember
them but it was something like the
following they said okay well we'll
define as copying if there's six words
in a row that are coming from sentence
in the training data
and then what percent of the text that
we're producing is copied in the sense
that it's six grams six words in a row
they're from the training data and the
answer that was really low it was
something like 3% and so it really
didn't seem that that was the case yeah
obviously you have to pick enough words
in a row because you can't kind of sort
of really blame it for sort of saying US
energy secretary or even something like
in an email to oh maybe this one does
get six words but you know you're
clearly going to get multi word units
that are the same and can't but this was
just a post hoc trying to get some sense
of it was this just copying stuff okay
yeah so yeah so the other I mean this
sort of stuff I haven't explained yet
which was actually apart from the one on
the right all of these other models that
I was talking about are actually a
somewhat different kind of model called
a transformer model which has been super
duper successful and in fact after GPT
two is that are now being this
increasing industry of a whole bunch of
new transformer models that are at large
scale and operating very well and I'm
not going to be able to sort of do all
the details of how transformers work but
I just want to give a little bit of a
sense of how things have changed and
what things are doing so there's this
central idea that's been used in most
work in empirical NLP where the idea is
that what we're going to do is represent
the meaning of words by their contexts
of use and you know this is sort of an
idea that has some tradition in
linguistics people often quote this
quota for mutual know a word by the
company it keeps and it's also an idea
that appear
and philosophy so that can in the later
writings of bit consigned he proposed a
use theory of meaning which is
essentially arguing that the meaning of
a word is the context in which you're
allowed to use it but you know for most
of linguistics and philosophy this is a
pretty fringe idea right so by and large
linguistics and philosophy have worked
with denotational models of semantics
which are in principle the same as the
kind of denotational models of semantics
people use for programming languages if
you've seen any of that kind of work but
under this model which is sort of a very
convenient model if what you have is a
lot of text data that you can munch
through if we want to have meanings of
banking or any other word what we're
saying is let's get a lot of text find
instances of the word banking and then
we're going to have all of this stuff
around it and say that these contexts of
use what is the meaning of the word
banking and you can hope to start to get
some ideas of sort of some of the things
that go on in banking by finding
sentences or having sentences that tell
you things that are connected up with
banking and so what is now sort of the
classic distributional model of word
meaning but classic means that six years
old I guess the speed of neural networks
was this word to vector that mclubbe at
others pioneered and so in the word
Tyvek model you'll wanted to learn a
meaning of a word a word type like in to
and you're going to find context in
which it appeared and what you wanted to
do is have a vector representation for
each word and therefore using that
vector representation directly in this
kind of softmax equation you wanted to
have the vector there's sort of the
vector product of the dot product
between two vectors appropriate normally
normalized as saying
actually give you the probability of two
words occurring in context well you're
just sort of predicting each individual
word independently which we call a bag
of words model so this was the model
that was proposed as a way of learning a
vector representation of each word and
essentially if you use this very simple
model over a lot of texts you've got a
representation for each word type so
banking crises into turning problems
that a first approximation was
semantically very good it really did
sort of show you notions of meaning
similarity really well you know I
haven't got it running here but you know
when in my class I just sort of run live
one of these word defect models and
people ask questions as to what words
are similar to other words you know
every year it freshly blows my mind just
how well at work such a simple model
getting word meanings and so it's this
kind of simple model that has been the
mainstay of a lot of the theoretical
work that's been done on word meaning
and deep learnings that includes work
like sanjeev Aurora's work if some of
you I've seen there with this is that
although it's sort of useful to you
learn one meaning for words and you can
argue that words have that the meaning
that you learn forward type is a
superposition of all its different
meanings in practice words have lots of
different meanings in context so if we
sort of look down these word meanings
for broke I broke the ice a bars at Vaes
and American English I broke the vase
the one broke he broke the silence the
news broke the machine broke I mean all
of these are so different right like I
broke the vars that's kind of the
starting basics of it right something
gets turned into pieces but when dawn
breaks nothing shadows and when you
break the silence nothing shadows either
machine broke
that's normally not broken in the center
have ours
sandy broke the world record sandy broke
the law there's something that sort of
seems to connect these different sensors
have broke but you know it's very hard
to actually put your finger on what and
you know traditionally people have used
an idea of saying a word has several
sensors it's very hard to actually get a
clear sense in your head as to which of
these different usages you might want to
clump together into a sense and which
ones you wouldn't want to it seems like
there's this very nebulous meaning where
words have very different meanings in
context and so the idea of the modern
language models are being used to
represent word meanings including these
transformer models is instead of coming
up with one meaning for a word what we
want to come up with is a meaning for
this token of the word broke here and a
different meaning for the Thoth this
total of the word broke here and a
different meaning for this token of the
word broke here where those meanings are
again going to be represented as a high
dimensional real vector that this time
it's going to be for served in this one
particular context how should we
represent its meaning so how can we do
that
well the way people are doing that in
transformer models is using this notion
of attention which is kind of in the way
in the abstract way connected to word to
bec because you're sort of looking at
the words surrounding you but so what
we've got is a word here and we're going
to mask it and then we're going to say
let's use the context to see if we could
reconstruct what that word is so the
sail up move the spinnaker okay well
these words will have a word
representation which could be a word to
that word representation you start off
with but we'll be trained by the model
as you train it and then what we're
going to do is do this attention
operation and so if the attention
operation
you take a dot product between each of
these vectors and calculate based on
those dot products are sort of a
similarity measure so these are our
attention scores and then you use those
attention scores to get a probability
weight over every context word saying
how much does each context word tell you
about this word in the middle so now
rather than just sort of having each
word predicted independent where you
were using all the words together with
weightings to say which ones of them are
important and so that gives you an
attention distribution and then once
you've got a probability attention
distribution you're then going to
calculate a weighted average of all of
these vectors to get an attention output
and I just copied this slide its
attention distribution but hopefully we
might want to learn that actually
spinnaker and sailor are the two most
predictive words in this context and so
then once we have that attention output
what we can do is take a representation
here and our tension output combined
them together by concatenated or
something similar and then put things
through softmax distribution again to
predict a word and we can hope to
predict a likely word in that context
and so we're running this model over a
lot of text but we're going to use this
model to predict representations of
words in contexts and so the Transformer
model is essentially built on this idea
of attention distributions and just
scales it up enormous ly to give an
enormous Liebig model of a kind that
theoreticians would hate so it seems
like it's maybe not so good to have only
one attention distribution because there
are lots of ways in which words can be
similar to and have relationships to and
interact with other words and context so
why don't we have 12 different attention
distributions at each position and
combine them together and so we do that
and well then maybe it's too simple to
just say that you do this attention
thing with 12 heads one time to produce
a new representation so why don't we
build a whole stack of these things
where we repeat our multi-headed
attention 12 times producing a really
deep neural network of the kind that
people you know this is sort of where
NLP people have envy of vision people
with their hundred layer networks
because most of NLP used to only use of
two three four layer networks so now we
can have a big stack of attention
distributions and have a deep network
and well maybe it's as well as the multi
head attention we could sort of stick
everything through feed-forward layers
at each stage as well to sort of have
learn parameters for a linear transform
to do things and we can put them all
together and have this sort of very deep
look around you many times and transform
things transform a network and lo and
behold these models have just proven to
be super super successful at then doing
prediction and they can sort of predict
all kinds of things so here are just a
couple of examples of this so the
Winograd schema challenge was an idea
proposed by Hector Levesque there's a
sort of an old AI guy and he said well
what we need is a problem which isn't
susceptible to sort of machine learning
and simple statistics something where
people need to really reason and think
and so he turned to some old sentences
from Terry Winograd 1980s book which he
had used to justify needing knowledge
and thinking sort of common-sense
knowledge of the world so if the
sentence is the city councilman refused
the demonstrators a permit because they
feared violence who that day is is the
city councilmen and to a human being
that makes sense because if someone's
refusing demonstrators a permit
we is the people refusing the city
councilmen that have feared the violence
but if we just change the word feared to
advocated the city councilmen refused
the demonstrators a permit because they
advocated violence well then what makes
sense to a human being is that they must
be referring back to the demonstrators
and so Hector Levesque suggested sort of
the reap using these kind of sentences
as a test of whether our systems
actually have knowledge about the world
to predict things and he wasn't
completely naive if you read his paper
there's a whole section of it where he
discusses you know this won't be a good
test if it's something that you can just
solve by using Google if you you know
can type a few words into Google and
look at the word counts and see that
City Councilman feared violence occurs a
lot more often than demonstrators feared
violence then maybe you could just do it
in a cheap way with statistics and he
managed to convince himself that that
wasn't actually doable and so that he
still thought in the sort of mid 2010 s
that this was a good test of whether we
had systems with common-sense knowledge
and so that idea has been built on
people made data sets have when the grad
scheme a challenge but it's just
actually proven to be wrong that these
huge language models just learn all of
this stuff so this is looking at sort of
scaling up a big language model this is
GPT to again from a hundred and
seventeen million parameters to 1.5
billion parameters training it over more
text and bigger models this was about
sixty three percent was the best
previous result that anyone had gotten
in the winter grad schema challenge some
of the models trying to do smarter
things with sort of common sense
knowledge
things like that but simply just
building bigger and bigger language
models of this Transformus size now
gives by far the best results on these
kind of windows grad schema challenges
don't have a number in my head but it
has been measured I think it's you know
humans are never perfect on things but I
think it's somewhere around 1992 right I
mean I by design these are meant to be
things that are fairly obvious to humans
and you know I presume these ones seem
pretty obvious to you and I'll you know
quite a few of the others have been some
sense they're even easier if they're
sort of talking about objects and their
interpretation
yeah humans do very well so that's a
good question
and my time is fast running out so I was
going to I was going to say a little bit
more about how good how good these
models are and what knowledge they
contain but it seems like I'm not gonna
have time to do that so I'll go on to
the end part that answers that sort of
seeks to answer your question I'll give
an answer to your question and at least
what I think yeah so these big
transformer language models have been
super duper successful here's one last
example of how SuperDuper successful
they've been so there's been a lot of
work by a whole bunch of groups on
question answering and the most used
data set has been the squad data said
that personally anal students built at
Stanford and so the idea of this data
set is that you have a passage Super
Bowl 50 was an American football game
determine the champion of National
Football League for the 2015 season and
the American Football Conference
champion Denver Broncos defeat of the
National Football Conference champion
and then you get a question of which
team won Super Bowl 50 and the answer is
the Denver Broncos
so these language models have been so
successful that firstly you can't be
competitive on this on this test unless
you use one of these big transformer
language models in particular from the
past year the most successful one has
been Bertha that's starting to change
now actually this is for the board from
February but you could see at this point
Bert Bert Bert Bert Bert Bert every
model was I was on the leader board was
Bert with some doodads and the second
thing that you could notice is these
models at this point we're getting
pretty much as good it's human
performance and actually over the last
six months have actually now beaten
human performance because humans aren't
perfect doing things that already here
they're sort of very close to human
performance so that's amazing but you
know on the other hand it's not the case
that these models seem perfect they
actually still do very dumb things so
here's a dumb example so this is talking
like about Dewar and dynasty and it says
in the middle here in official Chinese
histories the Yuan Dynasty bore the
Mandate of Heaven following the Song
Dynasty and preceding the Ming Dynasty
and the question was what dynasty came
before the UN and well you know this
sentence is a little bit complex I guess
because there's this hard to understand
bit here about bore the Mandate of
Heaven but you know it's pretty obvious
natural language understanding right the
Yuan Dynasty following the Sun dynasty
and preceding the Ming Dynasty so what
dinner Steve came before the you arms
should be the Song Dynasty three human
beings were asked to
so song dynasty the third one answered
Mongol Empire which you can sort of
justify from the first sentence I guess
it depends on whether you count the
Mongol Empire as a dynasty or not but at
least the temporal ordering of the human
beings third answer is also right but
here we ask this supposedly or wonderful
bird model and it answers Ming Dynasty
which seems you are pretty fundamental
and basic having no sort of
understanding of what the sentence is
actually saying and this is a behavior
that you notice instill in all in all of
the good question answering systems even
though they're so great that it seems
like a lot of the time the strategy you
get out of them is basically they're
really good at working out the semantics
type of the right answer and then they
somewhat that randomly choose an answer
of the right semantic type that's near
the centroid of words in the passage
that are similar to the question words
and so in terms of what's left so on the
one hand Burt and similar models have
been this super powerful pre-training
base for building natural language
understanding systems but nevertheless
they seem to have two problems so one of
them is that so it seems like they're
just a the currently most powerful way
of building a neural Association machine
that they can kind of sort of learn all
the statistics of what co-occurs with
what in a much better way than anything
that came before through these big
attention machines but they sort of just
sort of look for what seems to be
associated with what and choose
something that's associated they're not
really sort of thinking through the
meaning of a sentence so this is sort of
what does thinking mean and it seems
like one thing that if you're actually
thinking and reasoning you should
somehow be doing something more than
just sort of measuring the sensible
strength of associations with everything
but the second thing is that although
this model
a very good full language tasks like
this that we're still building just
these sort of one-off models for a
particular task that we're not actually
sort of using a model that clearly has
knowledge which can be deployed in
different ways and so in sort of going
further ahead it seems like what we'd
like to do is have models that can
flexibly redeploy knowledge and so we'd
like to be able to do things like that
are more in the nature of reasoning so
there was an influential paper from
early in the new current neural network
error from Leon burr to where he tried
to make an argument for how you might be
able to do reasoning in the context of
neural networks and well traditionally
recently has been the domain of logics
and hand-built knowledge representations
but he suggested that maybe we could
think about how we could use these learn
distributed representations as a way of
reasoning and you know what he suggested
is that maybe you could think about
reasoning as algebraically manipulating
previously acquired knowledge in order
to answer a new question so there are
ways that you could do that that aren't
don't have to be traditional methods for
logic so that as soon as you've got some
kind of algebraically rich inference
system that connects together trainable
learning systems that you could think of
being able to use those to do reasoning
and in particular he suggested that
central to reasoning is these
composition rules so that if you can put
things together in different ways to
address new tasks that is this sort of
composability of being have the
flexibility to do things in different
ways gives you something that's like
human reasoning and so an idea here is
that you know we have gone a long way in
neural networks with coming up with
designs
new net architectures that give us the
right kind of structure that allow us to
do tasks well so convolutions have been
famously useful for vision attention has
been the centerpiece of modern networks
gating has been incredibly useful leon
Batu's idea was essentially that we had
a short-term memory and when an input
came in we were getting two things out
of the short-term memory we are then
composing them to get a new partial
resolved which we get feedback into our
short-term memory and repeat so
essentially this architecture was
actually giving you a tree like
architecture but over thoughts so it
essentially looks exactly like the tree
like architectures with which I began
the talk but being using them over
thoughts so may be exactly that isn't
right but it seems like what we'd like
to be able to do is be able to sort of
replace our sort of fairly unstructured
correlation engines with some kind of
neural network design that allows
compositional and transparent multi-step
reasoning well having some of the good
attributes of things like transformer
models that they're end-to-end
differentiable and scalable to real
world problems and so that's the kind of
thing I've been interested in pursuing
and I'm kind of going to not have a lot
of time left now to tell you the details
of that but I'll just give you a sort of
a sense of the latest version of this
work so the most recent thing that we've
been exploring is the idea of a neural
state machine which is having a
differentiable graph based model that's
kind of like a traditional state machine
for combining neural and symbolic
approaches those so for solving problems
and we've been looking at this in the
domain of visual question-answering we
first of all
constructing an abstract semantic
representation in the form of a graph or
a state machine and then we're going to
be doing inference over that which is
sort of iterative computation over the
state machine so that we have an
internal alphabet of embedded concepts
the states are then a distribution over
those internal concepts the edges are
then transitions between concepts and so
when we then process with our neural
state machine we start with the
probability distribution of the initial
state and each step we have a neural
network calculating a state transition
function and so that will give us a
distribution over a next set so that if
we have a picture and then we're going
to be asked a question about that
picture we're going to from the picture
construct an abstracted C graph as our
neural state machine where States
correspondence and transitions
correspond to relations and then for the
objects they're going to have an
attention distribution over different
properties so what's going to go on here
is then we can work in this space of
abstract concepts and reasoning over
them by walking through the state graph
to be able to answer questions so if we
have a question like what is the red
fruit inside of the bowl to the right of
the coffeemaker we translate that into
an instruction sequence using an
attention based on code a decoder and
then we can start to reason it through
this state machine so we start with a
coffee maker we go to the right of it
that's indeed a ball we can look inside
it for something that's red and we can
answer that this is the Apple and so
this kind of system has by actually sort
of pulling apart these representations
is giving us ways to do a better job at
the
question answering so there have been
traditional ways of doing visual
question answering which have been
essentially convolutional neural
networks of the vision part and neural
sequence models for the language part
which have sort of works sort of but not
great and what I've been interested in
showing is that by using these more
explicit reasoning engines so Mac was an
early model that drew Hudson develop
working with me and this neural state
machine that we're actually able to do
much better jobs of reasoning and
understanding our work and so that's an
direction I'm hoping is very promising
for the future is how we can first of
all seek tasks that require some
multi-step compositional reasoning and
then try and build neural nets from that
in some sense do something more like
thinking by having so iterative
reasoning over more abstracted
disentangled concepts
[Applause]
that is a good question I mean there's
one answer which I one answer is in
certain places I think yes there
definitely is I mean way away from my
talk but an interesting place where
actually there's work going on between
formal logic and neural networks is one
of my colleagues at Stanford Michael
coach and works on aircraft systems like
collision avoidance systems and in the
new generation of his systems they're
actually coding them as neural networks
the reason they're coding them that way
is for compactness because they can have
much more compact models that they can
run on in less Hardware on a plane but
that sounds sort of scary because do you
want your planes collision avoidance
control by a neural network and so
they've gotten you know approval from
the FAA to run these models because
they're using formal logical you know
through formal logical theorem proving
methods to prove that this neural
network does not run amok so that's a
good example of how the two are coming
together relative to the traditional
idea of using formal logical inference
for something like natural language
understanding I mean at this point I'm
sort of skeptical that will work that
you know it's something that's being
tried for decades and language just
proves to be sort of too squishy soft
but things like how word meanings very
like those examples I showed with broke
and so I think we have to be seeking
something that you know has multi-step
inference like a logic that has more
softness than the traditional civil
[Applause]